[Music]
ready to roll on the Rich Eisen show
we're back live in Miami Florida I was
proud to call this man for seven years
on SportsCenter and I've been throw to
follow his show on audience for the last
five and a half he is my good friend
good buddies and patrica to see a DP
it's good good to be with you I tried to
match the Rich Eisen colors there with
the logo the RAS Miami yeah yeah where I
do that I do the Caruso thing for our
show open this year yeah I love that
yeah you know I really got into it damn
but really not into it is David Caruso
going to be here now he is not he is not
it's scheduled to appear he's not unless
there's a surprise that I don't know of
and he had that sunglasses thing where
not many other actors have mastered the
David Caruso well the thing that he
would do Dan is he would deliver the
line putting the sunglasses on that was
the Caruso touch the line and then and
the glass is on not like the glasses off
and line okay he would do the line
glasses on and that was the next level
thing from and I've been in a lot of
Sandler movies and I yes I haven't
learned acting like that
no but there's still time what what is
your greatest acting like Dan what are
you yes that you would say you know what
I'm most proud that I nail I stuck the
landing on that one
I carry strug dit yes you I I'm gonna
say the just go with it we're on the
night club owner yeah I've got Nicole
Kidman over here Jennifer Aniston over
here yeah they actually think I know
what I'm doing and I don't and just to
see their look of not panic but concern
just that they realized that I had no
idea what I was doing in the scene
because Sandler wrote a script
well there's he wrote a scene he just
didn't put any dialogue in there for me
yeah and I'm supposed to ad-lib this
nightclub scene with Dave Matthews Adam
Sandler Jennifer Aniston and Nicole
Kidman some heavy hitters yes and I get
up there and I go hey welcome to the
Oceana
that Club and I'm Dan Tanner and welcome
and and then it then it there's nothing
there
and so I stopped and Sandler is out
there in the audience directing it he
goes Danny what the your ad-lib and I
look around and I'm in terror because
I've got no Nicole Kidman staring at me
does she's an actress she's serious
she's like what is wrong with you and
then Aniston looks at me sort of the
same way and I was humbled I was
embarrassed by that and then I
eventually just started throwing out
lines and then Sandler goes that that's
that's better Danny let's just make it
better tomorrow and I okay Sandman and
so you did not just go with it is what I
did I did not if you would only gone
with it you're right
you know and and Nicole Kidman had me
figured out right from the start and
they have a green room by the way that's
a great that you could say something
like that yeah it's legit like yeah but
I went to the green room and I thought
okay as long as I don't run into Nicole
Kidman there yeah we're good yeah yeah
cuz I can talk with Jennifer Aniston a
little bit Nicole I I don't have it I
had one item to talk to her about my
daughter says if you see her that her
daughter's born on the same day as me I
go great I got that my back pocket go in
the green room Nicole Kidman walks in
and then it was the point of no return
where she just realized it was me in the
green room yeah she got ready to turn
around and then thought that might be a
little rude so she sat down didn't say a
word and I went my daughter shares a
birthday with your daughter she goes oh
that's nice so III had one line that I
could go with and I it didn't work and
then her handler I don't know I thought
she might have had a secret button to go
get me out of here when there's creepy
sports guy and their handler came in and
then she got up and left there's always
tomorrow damn there's always the next
one yeah but then her husband Keith
Urban shows up and could
not talk to me enough about the Titans
sure and so she's looking at him talking
to me right figuring likewise like who
is this see now if the Titans had only
won the AFC Championship game dad then
perhaps the Kidman urban Posse could
have made a year and we could have had a
mulligan now we don't want to have a
reunion if we could have only known them
with Keith Urban yet Nicole no I mean
great actress but man I had I had no
game to even have a normal conversation
dan Patrick here in the Rich Eisen show
you just finished your three-hour show
on the other side of the space here that
that we're sharing for the week
how much Super Bowl did you talk cuz
we're you know we're embarking on this
three-hour show that that just has so
much weighing over it because of what
happened yesterday with Kobe his
daughter and seven other souls DP what
was that you know I just talked about
I just tried to let it unfold naturally
and the guests that we had on we talk
some football with Michael Irvin Peter
King but then I had Reggie Miller and
Jerry West on and they were going to
talk about Kobe and I think you have to
put at least a period at the end of this
for just the coverage that wall-to-wall
coverage today right out of respect
because we weren't on yesterday if
there's more reaction tomorrow
Lakers Clippers tomorrow night but I
think the audience knows that you paid
tribute the best way you knew how to
today and you know whatever guests you
have everybody's gonna have a reaction
to this because everybody was affected
in some way and that's sort of the way I
just let if it was cathartic for
somebody to talk I let them talk sure
and if they you know didn't have a whole
lot to add then we just moved on when
was the first time you met Kobe
he was probably 21 or 22 and I always
admired his bravado like he had no
business having the bravado he had but
he did at 23 and he was cocky and I just
remember he's never gonna be able to
live up to that Verve I mean he came out
and he was there right there in front of
you and had so much confidence and
having covered Michael Jordan through
all those championship years you sort of
juxtaposition had the confidence but he
had won things right Kobe was just
really in the embryonic stages of his
career but he had as much confidence as
Michael did after Michael won all those
titles which is amazing why now do you
remember at the time that everyone's
like boy he's calling his shot with
Jordan I mean anybody who's ever done
that does not really have much to go for
themselves by the end of the basketball
day but he welcomed the comparison he
took the baton I don't know if they gave
it to him they he took the baton to say
I can be better than Jordan a lot of
guys back then shied away from any
comparison I remember Tracy McGrady and
Grant Hill in particular they're like oh
wait a minute here Kobe was like hey I'm
over here I'll take it they're like no
no you're too young - Kobe had had no
qualms about it and and there's certain
athletes you're around you know Tigers
always been that way and you saw that
where Tiger I think thought he could be
better than Jack Nicklaus Kobe thought
he could be better than Michael I don't
know if Tom Brady said I can be better
than Jill or at what point did he say
I'm better than Joe Montana right I
don't even know if he would say that
privately but how many athletes and how
many sports say I can be the best in my
respective sport and Kobe certainly did
that just like Tiger and you saw Tiger
had a relationship with Kobe and was
pretty broken up by that and the things
that stood out to Tiger Kobe blowing out
his Achilles and still going to the line
to shoot free-throws right so here's
Tiger winning a
u.s. open on a broken leg those are the
kind of things that I think resonated
with him well I mean Kobe went to the
line because if he didn't he would have
been ruled ineligible to return to the
game yeah just in case yet Achilles is
cop he got new AG pop is something that
he could come back yeah I got a new one
at 1/2 ton which is why you know what
happened yesterday is is so particularly
stunning amongst many other reasons dan
Patrick here on the Rich Eisen show I
first met Kobe on a SportsCenter
commercial shoot he came up to Bristol
and it was Stuart and I in the corner of
a break room and Kobe went up to the
machine to remove some you know to buy
some chips and all Stuart and I were
talking about is how he moved like
Jordan and ate the chips like Jordan and
Kobe was into that and Stuart and he had
some interesting moments together
because they were kind of one in the
same in the fact that you know as you
just read in the ringer a piece that was
the oral history about Stuart he thought
he was the best at what we were doing it
was gonna be the greatest of all times
no Dan Kobe was the same exact way and
the two of them just hit it off just
like that and I thought of Stuart
yesterday too for so many reasons and it
was just a Kobe is just it's similar
they have a similar personality was it
there the SportsCenter commercial with
Keyshawn Johnson and Kobe and right
Stuart and Kenny main we're teaching
them trash-talking yes right yeah I mean
and that is kind of
right and and the fact that Kobe had now
evolved into a coach in real life yeah
for his daughters yeah the whole thing I
can't even comprehend it it's so
difficult to compute well he had a
second career and a lot of these
athletes don't or they're not sure what
that second career is right because
you'll never match what this was in your
20s and 30s the highs that you have and
here's Kobe who matched it and then some
because his daughter kind of
reintroduced him to basketball and he
was falling in love with basketball
again he won an Academy Award he won an
Emmy and you could see where there's a
business side of him that was going to
be as determined to be great at that as
he was at basketball and you know I just
think that he he found something with
his daughters and the fact that she
wanted to go back and watch games and
have him teach her you know special
moment it's just and having you know
four kids and three daughters and you
just see you know birth and death of a
13 year old in
I know we lost other people on that
helicopter crash but you know when you
see when your child with those numbers
you know no parent should ever see those
numbers before I let you go Dan well
what do you think Super Bowl 54 looks
like what do you think the Chiefs at the
beginning of the year I'll stay with the
Chiefs I thought they were gonna play
the Eagles full disclosure but I think
that the Niners have a lot more
positives than Kansas City has but I
think it comes down to Kansas City has
Patrick mahomes and that's the reason
why they're favored because tight ends
are a push offensive line is maybe a
push or it's certainly the Niners
they're running a game as the Niners
defense is off San Francisco you got
Tyreke Hill is a big advantage and Andy
reading Kyle Shanahan might be a push
with calling plays so it comes down to
Patrick mahomes and can Patrick mahomes
win a game yes can Jimmy G win a game if
he has to I don't know yet
so if you chose the Chiefs no your why
does Eric Stonestreet think that you owe
him dinner because you took the Chargers
over the Chiefs you know he that was a
year ago
not this year you know he thinks this
yeah just to be on my show and yell at
me I know that and then as soon as he
yells at me I'm gonna go Eric I picked
the Chiefs this year right we're on the
same team again just it's not just him
because I I called him the night of the
AFC championship game to congratulate
him as a fan for his team to come to the
Super Bowl and he facetimed and not only
was he there but members of the Chiefs
offensive line was there and one of them
said to me you owe me dinner and
Stonestreet goes no that's Dan Patrick
this is Rich Eisen so it's not just Eric
Dan it is apparently those who protect
mahomes is coming and Eric I'm just
letting you I'm giving you this heads-up
for Friday
ok guys said the Chargers last year were
a better team than the Chiefs and would
go further that's it
this year I picked the Chiefs to win it
all these actors they don't know what
they strip he has no idea huh well
that'll be on Friday show Dan Patrick
show we wrestle I don't know how we
great oh well again we're just right
across the sector I can't wait to see
that on Friday yeah thanks for coming on
down you thank you guys
the show doesn't it wouldn't be here on
audience if it wasn't for this man yeah
and the Dan Patrick show every single
day at 9:00 a.m. Eastern Time along with
the day Nets that's Dan Patrick right
here for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
for free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app